you have a tear or two to tell when you
come back it'll promise that it will
come back
no and if you do you will not be discern
[Music]
so we saw the Hobbit tonight and we're
gonna wait a few days to post this so we
can you know give our thoughts and you
guys hopefully seen the movie already
because there's going to be a massive
spoilers in this video first of all I
want to say please don't get mad at us
yeah I should probably preface this and
we're gonna come up as super fanboy
nerds and like nitpicking it everything
but it's not an awful movie it's just it
has problems and we can't help but
notice it's kind of quite a few problems
yeah half of the movie has a problem and
the whole thing has one big problem I'm
gonna start by saying not to you just
fan the Lord of the Rings I like them I
understand why people like them the role
made but for me I was never into the
whole Frodo thing now the biggest issue
before we talk about plot points I guess
and all that is 48 frames per second
yeah that's a very distracting
yeah usually movies are 24 frames this
one's 48 so it's double the speed to me
it really took me out of the movie we
were wondering if it was going to be in
48 frames the screening and as soon as
the New Line Cinema logo came on the
screen we both were each other like 48
frames per second yes it was just like a
blurred pass really fast it was like
Benetton and the damn line whoa whoa do
you it did look it was the it's just
it's an adjustment and I will say that
after a while you got a little bit used
to it at first you know Bilbo's walking
through the Shire and his you know Bag
End or whatever his house is called and
it looks like he's like jittery and
weird and he's walking around all fast
and look I'm all for technological
advances I'm all for let's do a new
thing and see how it works but a lot of
this movie to me came off as an
experiment of some kind like it was they
were trying to do something with this 48
frames per second and some people will
probably watch it and be like oh this is
the next big thing but I think the
majority of people are going to find it
very distracting as we did yeah it's
unsettling it kind of takes out the
movie magic glow that really kind of
masks CGI and kind of blends it all
together yeah that's true that just made
everything pop out that was CGI or
artificial in the movie
um and another thing I was actually I've
heard a few people around us what's
wrong what's going on what's wrong with
this movie I heard a couple guys down
from us say that oh really
yeah well that's forty fingers per
second that's not how but we should look
and it kind of looked like a universal
theme park ride rather than a movie you
know some of the action scenes look cool
in 48 frames per second like I could see
that being part of a ride where you go
through it it's bumpy and then all of a
sudden that something jumps out of then
but not for a movie especially not for a
movie like this yeah I gotta agree and
okay so the 48 frames we you know we
didn't like it we both agree that looked
kinda like a video game graphics at
times you could just see the
imperfections like he said of various
CGI things I just didn't look as real
like the first three Lord of the Rings
films they were all almost entirely shot
in real locations whether it was a set
or somewhere in New Zealand and you even
if you weren't a big fan of it I loved
them you could appreciate it you can
appreciate it looked like they were shot
in a real place like you bought that
Aragorn was running up a mountain and
everything a lot of this movie really
felt kind of George Lucas II like like
stale environment you know yeah just
like here's that here's some slapped in
CGI we're not really gonna blend it and
we're gonna try to push technology
that's not quite ready to be pushed yet
I love the original three films if you
guys watched my my three reviews I did
leading up to the Hobbit I gave them all
an A+ my highest grade I love those
movies they're some of my favorite
movies I get that your aren't the
biggest fan of them to be honest though
I didn't actually have high expectations
going into this movie even though I
should because the last one one like 13
Oscars yeah I knew for some reason that
it wasn't going to live up to that so I
wasn't saying myself up for that there
are good things in this movie there
let's talk about if you won't get to him
well we'll get to him let's get the
shadow let's get it out of the way the
first like hour and a half was like a
snail yeah just dragging along like an
old woman who's decrepit who doesn't
have arms she's in a wheelchair going
uphill and I drove by in my car and she
looks at me but it's okay because I'm
the youth and not in the future very
accurate it can make sense at all
now the first hour and a half is yeah
nothing really happens and it's not like
I need uh paint no explosions or this or
that kind of way yeah cuz to be honest
even in the two towers you know there's
like one action scene and then Battle of
Helm's Deep the rest of the movie
a lot of planning and this and meeting
characters and everything but it's
really well done here there's something
about the fact that I think that there
are so many dwarves there's like what 13
dwarves yes let's build Lord to keep up
you can't really get attached to too
many characters you just there's Thorin
the main dwarf who is pretty cool
Gandalf who's I like Gandalf he's
awesome Bilbo Bilbo was you know I know
likes a little bit unlikable at first at
first and that's just I think that's
just because he was so like prissy about
everything like oh don't touch my
kitchen and everything yeah my plates my
plane right and then eventually he got a
little bit more into it the adventure
and he came a little bit more like old
it's just the first part of this movie
was it just was too slow and stagnant
yeah I like that one of the things that
I know about this movie that you know is
that originally it was supposed to be
two films in the middle of production
decided to make it into three films
cha-ching yeah I really think like
that's one of the reasons why this movie
was as slow as it was at the beginning
because it seemed like what might be an
extended edition blu-ray for like
hardcore games actually was the movie
and there was a lot of added scenes that
should have been removed I feel
basically 40 minutes of deleted footage
but it really didn't lead it the one
weird wizard who has the bird's nest in
his head with the rabbit sled real quick
insert a picture here what was the white
leaking off the top of his head
probably from the birds that were in a
just on his head we got he's a
wizard man Creason shampooed out
maybe your bunnies can eat it if there's
a character as a purpose no matter how
stupid stupid he is if he moves the plot
along fine so be it yeah but this guy's
10 minute 15 minute portion could have
been chopped out nobody would have known
the difference and that's that's the
truth now you said before there was kind
of like a George Lucas thing going on
and I know that's sad to say when you're
talking about The Hobbit Lord of the
Rings Peter Jackson but there's very
stagnant shots there's a term again
there's especially one where they go to
elf village mm-hmm whatever the hell
it's called Hugo Weaving standing there
they're sitting at a table for like ten
minutes just talking back and forth just
here's one shot here's the next shot
there's one shot here's the next shot
the whole conversation really doesn't go
anywhere it played no effect into the
plot or roll the movie no one's opinion
really mattered there nothing happens on
it was in the book that's fine one other
thing about that scene this movie had
what
movies have green screen effects that's
a given fine but there was something
about that particular scene where the
green screen effect really stood out
because it was like bad hair lighting on
Gandalf a lot of background glow yeah
like a halo effect going around people
it just really stood out and I think a
lot of that plays with the 48 frames per
second once again like I said we're
gonna come off super fanboy you know all
these problems and everything the movie
has good stuff in it the last like after
the first 90 minutes it really starts to
pick up when you get introduced to
Gollum it was really I thought that was
a great scene where the I think was the
best of the entire probably actually the
the riddle scene between Gollum and
Bilbo was really was really good and
that's the best CGI in the whole movie
is gone
yeah the motion capture like that was
the best I've ever seen Gollum really
good and the creepiest I've actually
seen Gollum you marry sweet juicy what
the hell I said what what does that
sound like it's close enough okay I was
close enough yeah cuz like in the two
towers or in turn of the king you kind
of felt bad for God like he was just
like this depressed like in this one
he's like who don't mess with him he's
coming for you like in the cavern a
scream and that scene was good and like
the whole end with the Eagles and you
know when they were falling from the
tree and Thorin had that like epic scene
where he just like stands up and he just
like runs in slow motion it was really
cool and I wished Moe over the movie was
like that it felt like that was what
Peter Jackson wanted to tell like that
part of the movie was like where his
real energy was but that was the meat of
the story yeah and I'll be honest with
you right then and that one scene once
again the 48 frames per second and she
looked good right there yeah cuz it was
in slow motion
and it wasn't like yeah and it paid off
that's where you can use things like
that but just to have people staying
there taking things out of a jar yeah
just look so natural like every time
Bilbo was like smoking his pipe look
that looked weird
how'd you do yeah what do they do you'll
see okay oh oh boy
but yeah with the last hour the movie
the big climax were there you know
underground and all kinds of action
everything's falling and reciting it was
cool but it felt like a ride it felt
like a virtual ride with the whole 48
frames per second the overuse of CGI it
just really was a big ceej
it was a lot of CGI there was a lie man
and for some reason there's a lot of CGI
and in The Lord of the Rings original
films they blend it better it did and I
don't know if that's just the 48 frames
or if it's just the fact that so much of
this was CGI because I just watched the
original 3 in preparation for the
reviews I did and a lie that was shot in
like real locations and they used like
CGI blended with actual things yeah
which is the best way to do CGI is when
you blend it with something that's
actually there it makes it easier to
accept it really just seems like this
movie maybe was originally like 2 hours
long oh yeah and after he decided to
make it 3 movies he's like huh we got
attack on this elf scene we got attack
on this this wizard with the rabbits
limb and tack on all this stuff and it
just seemed like he was trying to mesh
together a big almost three hour movie
so he could make a trilogy again or he's
trying to please too many people being
really faithful but in this movie they
felt like you know they had a little bit
more bowls and they're like let's just
CGI it it doesn't matter we have we had
the computer animation techniques today
to do it but sometimes it just looked
bad like the main orc of the movie who's
missing one arm or whatever you know
what that's true because in the original
Lord of the Rings films like every orc
was actually like an actor with makeup
yeah and this is random orcs in the
background would be CJ like every actor
with was an orc with makeup and you
bought that he was there because he
actually was like yes that's actually
very true like most of the orcs in this
movie were CGI completely yeah there's a
kind of I don't know if they got lazy or
what they had to do but I will say like
for me being a big fan of oil rigs when
Elijah Wood came on the beginning I did
get a big smile on my face made me happy
did yeah yeah I couldn't I couldn't
focus because it look like a shot with
the camcorder
I'm just moving around all fast and look
I even put too much lighting overall
like if you guys saw my review you know
that I will say see the film because
it's a film you shouldn't see you know
it's just very disappointing from the
standpoint of the fact that this last
the last one swept the Oscars won Best
Picture you know tons of fans of these
movies I would like to be that guy
that's like oh it's okay Alex I'll look
over this I can't I
can't do it it's just there's too many
flaws for me to fully recommend it to
you and that's pretty much how I feel
about the film yeah I feel like if they
could have just chopped out an hour 45
minutes just something to make it go a
little bit faster and just take out the
fluff that was just completely
unnecessary if you guys can tell me what
the bunny scene with the wizard had to
do with the plot that moved it along
well dude it was with a book let me know
down below what that played into the
story the last hour the movie I really
liked I wasn't that's what really saved
it for me I mean like that's like you
said that seemed like that was the story
he want oh yeah and the first hour kind
of killed it for me if you guys haven't
checked out John's channel do so please
he does a lot of videos and they're good
they're entertaining they're sad but
funny I don't know it's your opinion
just come check it out best type of fun
yeah anyway guys if you haven't checked
out my buddy stuckness channel check him
out movie reviews for every single movie
that comes up good or bad I he'll be
there to tell you about it I think we
should say one more positive thing about
the movie let's say we're gonna throw it
in there um like what god if you guys
want to see what 48 frames per second
looks like and how it can destroy CGI
even in a movie created by Peter Jackson
Lord of the Rings
you know the Hobbit Wetty that one of
the best CGI companies out there this
movie destroys their work 48 frames per
second go to hell stop that should be
saved for a niche movie like a junkie
you know like some kind of junk ass
movie like final destination 19 that
should be 48 frames per seconds to test
it yeah just that put it there
let the teenagers watch it there's blood
there's gore cool okay now for movies
like this got it thanks for watching
guys if you want to see The Hobbit let
us know what you thought about it like I
said it's not an awful movie it's just
it has problems but let us know how you
felt about it maybe you loved that maybe
you absolutely hated it let us know
below I know you
is Bilbo Baggins watches Bagginses
[Music]